c'est dans une salle d'audience troupes
et web que face déroulée cette dernière
journée d'audience
lewis elle a 43 ans l'organisateur de
soirées présentées dans ce dossier comme
le boss le tonton mêmes lewis hamilton
on rejette en bloc tous ses pseudonymes
qu'on lui attribue très longuement
interrogé à la barre par le président du
tribunal correctionnel de fort-de-france
et nie les faits qui lui sont reprochés
dans ce trafic de cocaïne et ça laisse
même très poliment président en lui
déclarant je cite vous avez ma vie entre
vos mains
permettez monsieur le président que je
me défende
bien qu'il soit mis en cause dans ce
trafic est confronté à bruno f
le fonctionnaire de police qui ouvrait
les portes de contrôle et aussi à bruno
m qui apparaît comme le logisticiennes
ce réseau lewis se montrer ferme et
contestent leurs déclarations concernant
la transaction et le paiement de facture
très importante
il répond à la représentante du parquet
qu'il organisait plusieurs soirées dramé
ce qui lui était largement bénéfique
le champagne par exemple qu'il achetait
à 20 euros étaient revendus de 60 à 70
euros au client
l'homme précise aussi qu'il est un
passionné de jeu à la limite du
professionnel et qu'il a surtout
beaucoup de chance au poker il n'a pas
de difficultés financières
il fait des prêts depuis hier autres
employés du fret aérien de la compagnie
aérienne
tous les autres prévenus ont reconnu les
faits des prévenus acquis leur reprocher
sur le ressort de la jirs sein de fort
de france et en région parisienne
d'avoir entre le 1er août 2013 et le 19
août 2016 participé à ce trafic un délit
puni de dix ans d'emprisonnement
demain dernière journée d'audience les
huit avocats tenteront d'exploiter
toutes les failles de cette procédure a
fait de minimiser l'action de leurs
clients